uh so listen man uh how many Blanco's
are you gonna do
seven seven of them I'm capping it at
seven
is that because it's like a just it just
feels right I mean God created the world
in six days and rested on the seventh
um
you had that the god number you know
it's the god number you have a seven on
your face as well yeah yeah yeah
my dad had seven seven all right this
new uh uh Blanco you somehow got a Stan
interpolation cleared
yeah what is the process of getting
Eminem clearance
so the process of getting an m m
clearance is not getting Eminem to clear
it it's getting Dido declare it because
it was her vote and it was her original
sample nothing off of the stand sample
so when I came out with the [__] like
and told everybody I'm like I just
cleared the stand sample because to me
those words well people don't know that
that she was that song was her own song
sampled that she sent it from her yeah
so basically how it happened I was I was
out here in La I laid this song you know
um
just on some freestyle [__] because I'm
really independent so I don't know how
it goes with uh clearing samples I stay
away from all of that right you know
what I mean I never even thought it
would be possible right so I laid this
song
um my man 10 is just on the iPhone real
quick did a uh a video of me like
singing this [__]
in the crib and
you know it got millions of views online
so my distribution perfect time music
they were like hitting me like yo this
[__] got motion I think we should try to
clear it and I'm like go ahead and he
found some lady who knows about
clearance samples and then she got it to
Dido and Dido okayed it you know took a
little percentage of the record and I
mean not yeah and yeah and we had it so
a lot of my fans were mad because the
song was like short but that's the way
that I did it in the studio because I'm
like this is like a freestyle for me to
listen to or like to put out on YouTube
so by the time I got the sample cleared
I'm like [__] it I'm gonna just put it
out in this raw form and I did an
extended version that comes with the
albums that's the process of getting an
Eminem sample cleared you just just get
one of the records that he sampled so
you don't have to go through him yeah
yeah it'd be like if someone's tried to
clear it Sing for the Moment be like
it's not an Eminem song it's an
Aerosmith yeah yeah but I would still
say I was clear this Sing for the Moment
sample oh man you and Ray Sherman got a
song coming soon maybe me and Swae Lee
yeah we got a disc record coming against
against Jimmy
that was kind of a weird thing man I saw
that I was like why the [__] was
somebody and I know Jimmy he's a good
dude I just I just didn't understand
like
I mean maybe it's just a way to promote
your own [__] but I don't understand the
thought process of [__] on somebody
else to promote your own [__] you know
what it was I think I think my [__] was
getting traction like my [__] was having
emotion online like well damn that was
the same thing that was their rollout
like we cleared the stand sample but I'm
a marketing guy so I already know that
so as soon as as soon as I cleared it
I'll put it out there yeah and you know
sites at rap started picking it up it
started going crazy and
the next day
I saw like Swae Lee's Camp pushing his
[__] on Twitter Swae Lee cleared the
sample I'm like oh no they're panicking
they must have saw my my joint out there
and uh that's when my ship kept going
crazy on academics and it helps and it
just helps your [__] yeah Slim Jimmy
wrote about it and it brought more
awareness so you know salute thanks to
him for the free promo nah and I really
like them as a group I talked to Swae
Lee you know Swae Lee's cool and I could
never have beef with like race trimmer
that's like being a bully like that
right yeah you know